When Lucian Truscott tries to explain how he's related to Thomas Jefferson, he says, OK, he's 73. He used to visit a great grandmother, who used to visit her great grandfather, Thomas Jefferson's grandson.
当卢西安·特拉斯科特试图解释他和托马斯·杰斐逊的关系时，他说，好吧，他今年73岁。他过去常去探望一位曾祖母，而她过去常去探望她的曾祖父，即托马斯·杰斐逊的孙子。
So there was only-- when I was growing up, when I visited my great grandmother, there was only one dead person between me and Jefferson.
所以，在我成长过程中，当我探望我的曾祖母时，我和杰斐逊之间只有一个已故的人。
When Lucian was a boy in the early 1950s, just six or seven years old, when he would visit family in Charlottesville, sometimes they would drop him off with his brother at Monticello, Jefferson's home. Lucian says it was before the place had been remade for tourists like it is today. Basically, visitors who pay maybe $1 and walk through the house.
当卢西安在20世纪50年代初还是个六七岁的男孩时，他去夏洛茨维尔探望家人，有时他们会把他和弟弟送到杰斐逊的故居蒙蒂塞洛。卢西安说，那时这里还没有像今天这样为游客重建。基本上，访客付个一美元左右，就能在屋子里转一圈。
You know, my great aunts, they treated the place like it was still the family home. And we had the run of the place. We used to fill our pockets full of pebbles from the walkways up there, and go up on the second floor and third floor of the place and crawl out windows onto these parapets that are up around the top of Monticello and drop pebbles on the tourists that were walking around the house. And--
你知道，我的姑婆们把这里当作家族的家。我们在那里可以随意跑动。我们常把口袋装满走道上的鹅卵石，然后上到二楼和三楼，从窗户爬到蒙蒂塞洛顶部周围的护墙上，把鹅卵石扔向在屋子周围参观的游客。而且……
Very asocial behavior.
非常反社会的行为。
Yeah. And you're talking to one of-- probably the only person you'll ever talk to in your life that's actually jumped on Thomas Jefferson's bed. I mean, we would play on the bed. We'd go through that little doorway and up the stairs into the closet, which is above the bed there, and sit up there in the closet. And when tourists came through the room, we'd stick our faces out of the window up there and say boo and scare them. We'd hide out there. And so--
是的。而且你正在和一个人交谈——可能是你这辈子会交谈的唯一一个真的在托马斯·杰斐逊的床上跳过的人。我是说，我们会在那张床上玩。我们会穿过那个小门口，沿着楼梯爬进床上的衣柜里，坐在那儿。当游客走进房间时，我们会把脸从上面的窗户探出来大喊“嘘”来吓唬他们。我们会躲在那里。所以……
There was no adult supervision at all.
根本没有任何成年人监管。
No, no adult supervision at all.
没有，完全没有成年人监管。
We went through all the bedrooms and stuff up there. And then, of course, we'd play down in the basement rooms. And then of course what they call the dependencies, which were the slave rooms that run under the two wings that run out from Monticello itself.
我们翻遍了上面所有的卧室之类的东西。然后，当然，我们会在地下室的房间里玩。当然，还有他们所谓的“附属建筑”，也就是在蒙蒂塞洛本身延伸出来的两翼下面的奴隶房间。
It would be decades before the slave quarters were part of the Monticello tour, Lucian says. These were just empty rooms under the house. No furniture or anything else in them. He and his brother would explore and run around.
卢西安说，要过几十年，奴隶住所才会成为蒙蒂塞洛参观路线的一部分。这些只是房子下面空荡荡的房间。里面没有家具或其他任何东西。他和弟弟会在里面探险，跑来跑去。
And play hide and seek or whatever little boys did.
玩捉迷藏或者小男孩玩的那种游戏。
It's amazing to me the degree to which it felt like a family home. Did it feel that way to you as a kid?
我觉得很神奇，它在某种程度上让人感觉像个家。你小时候有这种感觉吗？
You know, I have to tell you that all of this stuff in my family was just taken for granted.
你知道，我得告诉你，在我家里，所有这些东西都被认为是理所当然的。
These days, of course, nothing about the legacies of the Founding Fathers is taken for granted. Just this week, a special committee appointed by the mayor of Washington, DC called for removing, relocating, or contextualizing a bunch of monuments to slave-owning Founding Fathers, including the Jefferson Memorial and the Washington Monument, which, by the way, the mayor doesn't actually have jurisdiction over.
当然，如今，关于国父们的遗产，没有什么是被视为理所当然的了。就在本周，华盛顿特区市长任命的一个特别委员会呼吁移除、搬迁或重新诠释一群奴隶主国父的纪念碑，包括杰斐逊纪念堂和华盛顿纪念碑，顺便说一句，市长实际上对这些并没有管辖权。
Meanwhile, the president, of course, has put his arms around this issue. Right after he began his reelection campaign, he gave a speech at Mount Rushmore to make clear that he does not want to remove any monuments or rename any buildings or military bases.
与此同时，总统当然已经介入了这个问题。在他开始竞选连任后不久，他在拉什莫尔山发表了演讲，明确表示他不希望移除任何纪念碑或重命名任何建筑物或军事基地。
But this great, great, great-- whatever it is-- direct descendant of Thomas Jefferson, Lucian Truscott, he's got a special perspective on this. He led the charge to convince all the other white descendants of Thomas Jefferson to allow the Black descendants of Thomas Jefferson into their official family association.
可能不行。我是说，那个时代有趣的是，他们真的觉得自己是在保存。这就是他们在自己头脑中证明它的方式，他们实际上是在帮助保护它，这是不可避免的。这是天命论（Manifest Destiny）的早期思想，认为这必然会发生。
The Black family members, of course, trace back to Jefferson and Sally Hemings, one of the people he enslaved. Lucian thinks that everybody needs to get real about the slave-owning past of some of the Founding Fathers.
黑人家庭成员当然可以追溯到杰斐逊和莎莉·海明斯，她是杰斐逊奴役的人之一。卢西安认为，每个人都需要认清一些国父们的奴隶制历史。
Like, how do you feel about people taking down monuments of Thomas Jefferson?
比如，你对人们拆除托马斯·杰斐逊纪念碑有什么看法？
I think they ought to be taken down. I think that the great monument to Thomas Jefferson is Monticello. And I think it's an appropriate monument, because it actually puts Jefferson's life in context. It puts his slave-owning as part of his life and in context. If you visit Monticello today, you get to see where the slaves lived. You'll be shown where Sally Hemings's brother John did woodwork in Jefferson's bedroom, and study, and so forth.
我认为它们应该被拆除。我认为托马斯·杰斐逊伟大的纪念碑是蒙蒂塞洛。我认为这是一个合适的纪念碑，因为它实际上把杰斐逊的生活放在了历史背景中。它把他的奴隶主身份作为他生活的一部分并放在了背景中。如果你今天参观蒙蒂塞洛，你会看到奴隶们住的地方。你会看到莎莉·海明斯的兄弟约翰在杰斐逊的卧室和书房等地做木工的地方。
Slaves built that place. I never heard that slaves built that place when I was growing up. But it's talked about today. The history of Monticello at this point is about half Jefferson history, half slave history. I think that's appropriate. As a memorial, it tells the story of the whole man, not just this sort of god-like Thomas Jefferson we've all been raised to venerate.
奴隶们建造了那个地方。我在成长过程中从未听说过奴隶们建造了那个地方。但今天人们在谈论它。此时蒙蒂塞洛的历史大约有一半是杰斐逊的历史，一半是奴隶的历史。我认为这很合适。作为一座纪念馆，它讲述了一个完整的人的故事，而不仅仅是我们从小被灌输要崇拜的那种神一般的托马斯·杰斐逊。
What are we supposed to do with the shameful parts of America's past? This is being talked about so much today. And back in the early days of our radio show, in the late '90s, one of our contributors, Sarah Vowell, did a story that took that on in this very vivid and complicated way.
我们该如何处理美国历史上可耻的部分？今天人们对此谈论得非常多。在我们的广播节目早期的日子里，也就是90年代末，我们的撰稿人莎拉·沃威尔做过一个故事，以一种非常生动且复杂的方式探讨了这个问题。
She set out on the road with her sister Amy to visit the site of a historic tragedy, one that involved part of their own family 160 years before that. And we wanted to replay it this holiday weekend because the questions that it addresses, the things that it is obsessed with, are all so much more talked about today than 22 years ago when she did that story.
她和妹妹艾米踏上了旅程，去访问一个历史悲剧发生地，这涉及她们自己家族160年前的一部分。我们想在这个假期周末重播它，因为这些问题，这些它所执着的事情，与22年前她做那个故事时相比，在今天被谈论得更多。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. We take a road trip into history today. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，我们要进行一次历史公路之旅。请留在我们身边。
So Sarah Vowell and her sister Amy were born in eastern Oklahoma, in what was called Indian Territory before statehood. That's where our story ends, and that's also where it begins. They're enrolled citizens of the Cherokee Nation, like their parents, which, as you'll hear, is important to this story.
莎拉·沃威尔和妹妹艾米出生在俄克拉荷马州东部，在建州前被称为印第安领地。我们的故事在那里结束，也是从那里开始。像她们的父母一样，她们是切罗基族的登记公民，正如你将听到的，这对这个故事很重要。
Here's the opening line of Sarah's story from 1998.
以下是莎拉1998年故事的开场白。
Being at least a little Cherokee in northeastern Oklahoma is about as rare and remarkable as being a Michael Jordan fan in Chicago. I mean, who isn't?
在俄克拉荷马州东北部，拥有哪怕一点点切罗基血统，就像在芝加哥成为迈克尔·乔丹的粉丝一样稀有且引人注目。我是说，谁不是呢？
I'm guessing I don't need to explain that antique 1998 sports reference to many of you, but I do have one note before we play the rest of the story. And it's about the word "Injun." Sarah asked me to point out to anyone hearing this today that her grandfather was born in Indian Territory before statehood. And he used the word "Injun" as a term of affection. It was never derogatory. OK, so picking up, Sarah's part Cherokee.
我想我不需要向你们大多数人解释那个1998年的体育典故，但在播放故事的其余部分之前，我有一个说明。是关于“Injun”（印第安人）这个词。莎拉让我提醒今天听到这个词的任何人，她的祖父出生在建州前的印第安领地。他用“Injun”这个词作为一种爱称。它从来没有贬义。好的，接下来说，莎拉有切罗基血统。
It goes without saying that my twin sister Amy is, too, except that I have dark eyes and dark hair, and she's a blue-eyed blonde. And so our grandfather nicknamed me Injun and her Swede.
不用说，我的双胞胎妹妹艾米也有，只是我有深色的眼睛和深色的头发，而她是蓝眼睛的金发女郎。所以我们的祖父给我起了个绰号叫“Injun”（印第安人），给她起名叫“Swede”（瑞典人）。
Here's Amy's take on all this. I must point out that while my sister and I don't really look alike, we sound almost exactly alike. A hint for listening to this story, I'm usually the grouchy one. Here's Amy.
这是艾米对这一切的看法。我必须指出，虽然我和妹妹长得不太像，但我们听起来几乎一模一样。听这个故事的一个小贴士：通常我才是那个爱发牢骚的人。艾米来了。
I mean, those roles were assigned to us, you know, Indian and Swede, because of the way we looked. But it was also more like the things we were told about ourselves, and she was the one who was given the Cherokee language book. And I was the one who was always told how much alike I was to our Swedish grandmother. And I think I was probably 6 or 7 or something before I realized that I was Cherokee, too.
我是说，这些角色是分配给我们的，你知道，印第安人和瑞典人，因为我们长相的原因。但这更像是关于我们自己的说法，她是那个拿到切罗基语书的人。而我总是被告知我长得有多像我们瑞典籍的祖母。我想我大概是6岁或7岁左右才意识到我自己也是切罗基人。
We're a little French, and Scottish, and English, and Seminole, too. Typical American mutts. But the Cherokee and Swedish sides of the family were the only genealogies anyone knew anything about. Here's what we knew about ourselves.
我们也有一点法国、苏格兰、英国和塞米诺尔血统。典型的美国杂种。但切罗基和瑞典这两边的家庭是我们唯一了解家谱的。这就是我们对自己所了解的情况。
Ellis Island, Trail of Tears. And I think, to a kid, Trail of Tears, the Cherokees' forced march from the East to Oklahoma, where we were born, seemed enormously more interesting, just as a name. Even the smallest children know what tears mean. And I think in my earliest understanding of where I came from, I pictured myself descended from a long line of weepers with bloodshot eyes.
埃利斯岛，眼泪之路。我觉得，对一个孩子来说，“眼泪之路”——切罗基人从东部被迫迁徙到我们出生的俄克拉荷马州——仅仅作为一个名字，看起来就极其有趣。即使是最小的孩子也知道眼泪是什么意思。我想在我最初理解自己来自哪里时，我把自己想象成一群泪流满面、双眼充血的人的后代。
The Trail of Tears. Between 1838 and '39, the US army wrenched 16,000 people from their homes, rounded them up in stockades, and marched them across the country. 4,000 died.
眼泪之路。1838年到1839年间，美国军队将16000人从家中强行驱离，把他们关进木栅栏，并将他们驱赶到全国各地。4000人因此丧生。
Every summer when we were children, our parents would drive us to a place about half an hour from where we lived called Tsa-La-Gi, which is the Cherokee word for "Cherokee." Tsa-La-Gi is the tribe's cultural center. There's a recreated village, a museum. And this was our favorite part, an amphitheater which staged a dramatic recreation of the Trail of Tears.
小时候的每个夏天，我们的父母都会开车带我们去离我们住的地方大约半小时车程的一个叫Tsa-La-Gi的地方，这是切罗基语中“切罗基”的意思。Tsa-La-Gi是部落的文化中心。那里有一个重建的村庄、一个博物馆。而这是我们最喜欢的部分，一个上演眼泪之路戏剧重现的露天剧场。
Every summer, we watched Chief John Ross try like mad to save the Cherokee land back East. We saw his hothead rival, Stand Watie, rage off to the Civil War. We especially loved the Death of the Phoenix, a noisy, magenta-lit, interpretive dance in which the mythic bird would die only to rise again.
每年夏天，我们都会看着约翰·罗斯酋长疯狂地试图挽救东部的切罗基土地。我们看到他那急躁的对手斯坦·瓦蒂愤怒地冲进了南北战争。我们特别喜欢“凤凰之死”，那是一场嘈杂的、洋红光照射下的解释性舞蹈，神话中的鸟会死去，然后又重生。
We would get these programs or brochures, and Sarah was kind of in charge of them. And sometimes she'd let me look at them. She had a whole little file, and we would look through them. And it was-- I mean, I did take it to heart. It was a story that was really tragic. I have a reverent feeling towards it. And I think it's because of this play, because this play was so serious and told such a detailed story, that it took this place of significance, like it was really important and it really mattered.
我们会拿到这些节目单或手册，莎拉负责保管它们。有时她会让我看。她有一个完整的小档案，我们会翻看它们。那真的很——我是说，我确实把它放在心上了。这是一个非常悲惨的故事。我对它有一种崇敬的感觉。我认为是因为这部戏，因为这部戏太严肃了，讲述了一个如此详细的故事，以至于它占据了重要的地位，仿佛它真的很重要，而且真的很重要。
Here's the measure of how important the amphitheater show was to Amy and me. Our father and our grandfather used to show us photographs of Cherokee leaders in books, but even now, when I imagine Stand Watie, I picture the actor at Tsa-La-Gi.
这是露天剧场的表演对艾米和我有多重要的衡量标准。我们的父亲和祖父过去常在书里给我们看切罗基领导人的照片，但即使是现在，当我想到斯坦·瓦蒂时，我脑海中浮现的也是Tsa-La-Gi里的那位演员。
So all my life, I knew I wouldn't exist but for the Trail of Tears, and it struck me as a little silly that most of the things I knew about it were based on an amphitheater drama I haven't seen for nearly 20 years.
所以这一生，我知道如果没有眼泪之路我就不会存在，而我知道的大部分关于它的事情都是基于一部我快20年没看过的露天剧场戏剧，这让我觉得有点傻。
At first, I thought I'd read some books about it, which I did. But then I wanted to see it, feel it, know how long a trek it was. I wanted it to be real. I enlisted Amy. Perhaps she'd like to do all the driving? A historical tragedy in five 14 hour days behind the wheel? Who could pass that up?
起初，我想我会读一些关于它的书，我也确实读了。但后来我想亲眼看看，感受一下，了解那段跋涉有多漫长。我希望它是真实的。我拉上了艾米。也许她想负责开车？在方向盘后面度过五个14小时的历史悲剧之旅？谁能拒绝呢？
And so I fly from Chicago, she from Montana, and one spring morning, we find ourselves in a rental car on our way to northwestern Georgia, the homeland of the Cherokee before they were shoved out to Oklahoma, the place the Trail of Tears begins.
于是我从芝加哥飞过来，她从蒙大拿州飞过来，一个春天的早晨，我们发现自己坐在一辆租来的车里，正前往乔治亚州西北部，那是切罗基人在被驱赶到俄克拉荷马州之前的家园，也就是眼泪之路开始的地方。
The Cherokee Territory once encompassed most of present day Tennessee and Kentucky, as well as parts of Alabama, Georgia, Virginia, and the Carolinas. Even before contact with the Europeans in 1540, they were a proto-democratic society. They built these enormous council houses, big enough to fit the entire tribe inside, so everyone could participate in tribal decisions.
切罗基领地曾经覆盖了现今田纳西州和肯塔基州的大部分地区，以及阿拉巴马州、乔治亚州、弗吉尼亚州和卡罗来纳州的部分地区。甚至在1540年与欧洲人接触之前，他们就是一个原始民主社会。他们建造了巨大的议会大楼，大到可以容纳整个部落，这样每个人都可以参与部落决策。
We're barely on the road an hour when we spot them. Injuns, ceramic ones, three feet tall at a shack on the side of the road. Amy drives past them, we do a double take, and we don't even discuss whether or not to stop. She just backs up immediately and parks.
我们上路不到一小时就发现了它们。印第安人，陶瓷做的，三英尺高，在路边的一个棚屋里。艾米开车经过它们，我们回头又看了一眼，甚至都没讨论要不要停下来。她直接倒车停了下来。
Are you of Native American descent?
你是美洲原住民后裔吗？
I'm a Mexican, from Texas.
我是墨西哥人，来自德克萨斯州。
From Texas? And what brought you to Calhoun, Georgia?
来自德克萨斯州？是什么把你带到乔治亚州卡尔霍恩的？
The work.
工作。
The eight little Indians he's selling are of the kitschy teepee-toting Plains Indians variety, which are probably a lot easier to sell than the stereotypical image of a Cherokee, a tired out old woman, tromping through the Trail of Tears in rags. Who wants that as a lawn ornament?
他卖的那八个小印第安人属于那种俗气的、带着帐篷的平原印第安人风格，这可能比切罗基人的刻板印象——一个疲惫不堪的老妇人，穿着破烂走在眼泪之路上——要容易卖得多。谁会想要那个作为草坪装饰品呢？
Who buys these statues, these Indian statues?
谁买这些雕像，这些印第安雕像？
People here from Calhoun, around Georgia. People here around Georgia love Indians.
卡尔霍恩当地人，乔治亚州周围的人。乔治亚州周围的人热爱印第安人。
Really?
真的吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯。
Well, after they got rid of them?
好吧，在他们把他们赶走之后？
Oh, that's right. That's true. You're telling the truth there.
哦，没错。那是真的。你说的是实话。
Thank you very much.
非常感谢。
The Cherokee, especially the mixed bloods, were always your nerdy, overachiever, bookish sort of tribe. And in the early 19th century, they launched a series of initiatives directly imitating the new American republic. In one decade, they created a written language, started a free press, ratified a constitution, and founded a capital city.
切罗基人，尤其是混血儿，总是那种书呆子、追求上进、书卷气的部落。在19世纪初，他们发起了一系列直接模仿新美国共和国的倡议。在十年内，他们创造了一种书面语言，创办了自由媒体，批准了一部宪法，并建立了一个首都城市。
New Echota was that capital. Now it stands in the middle of nowhere, a Georgia State Park with a handful of buildings across from a golf course.
新埃科塔就是那个首都。现在它坐落在荒郊野外，是一个乔治亚州立公园，在一家高尔夫球场对面有几栋建筑。
Can we follow you in this car?
我们可以开车跟在你后面吗？
Drive on in.
开进来吧。
New Echota was founded in 1825. To call it the Cherokee version of Washington, DC is entirely applicable, given the form of government the tribe established there. They ratified a constitution based on that of the United States, dividing into legislative, judicial, and executive branches. Its preamble begins "we, the representatives of the people of the Cherokee Nation, in convention assembled in order to establish justice, ensure tranquility, promote our common welfare, and secure to ourselves and our posterity the blessings of liberty."
新埃科塔建于1825年。鉴于该部落在那里建立的政府形式，称其为切罗基版的华盛顿特区是完全适用的。他们批准了一部基于美国宪法的宪法，分为立法、司法和行政部门。它的序言以“我们，切罗基民族的代表，在大会召集下，为了确立正义，确保安宁，促进我们的共同福祉，并确保我们自己和我们的后代享有自由的祝福”开头。
Unlike Washington, New Echota is cool, and quiet, and green. Site manager David Gomez showed us around the grounds, and Amy and I were unprepared for the loveliness of the place, for its calm lushness, its fragrance. Everywhere, honeysuckle was in bloom.
与华盛顿不同，新埃科塔凉爽、安静、绿意盎然。现场经理大卫·戈麦斯带我们参观了场地，艾米和我对这个地方的美丽，以及它的宁静、葱郁和芬芳毫无准备。到处都是盛开的金银花。
I like it here.
我喜欢这里。
It's nice. It's peaceful, and it's right for the-- the atmosphere is right for what was going on in the story that we tell here. It's a story that's sad in a lot of ways, but there was a lot of great things happening with the Cherokee Nation.
它很好。它很安静，而且适合……气氛适合我们在这里讲述的故事。这是一个在很多方面都很悲伤的故事，但切罗基民族也发生了很多伟大的事情。
The Cherokee, along with the other southeastern tribes who suffered removal to Oklahoma-- the Chickasaw, the Creek, the Choctaw, the Seminole-- are one of the so-called five civilized tribes.
切罗基人，以及其他在俄克拉荷马州遭受驱逐的东南部落——奇卡索人、克里克人、乔克托人、塞米诺尔人——被称为所谓的五个文明部落之一。
It was in 1822 that the Cherokee hero, Sequoyah, developed an alphabet, inventing the sole written language of any North American tribe. Only six years later, Cherokee editor Elias Boudinot founded The Cherokee Phoenix, a bilingual English-Cherokee newspaper published at New Echota.
正是1822年，切罗基英雄塞阔雅开发了一种字母表，发明了任何北美部落唯一的书面语言。仅六年后的1828年，切罗基编辑伊莱亚斯·布迪诺特在新埃科塔创办了英切双语报纸《切罗基凤凰报》。
Many Cherokee, especially the mixed bloods, practiced Christianity. And because many of these lived as civilized, Southern gentlemen of the early 19th century, they owned prospering plantations, which meant they owned Black slaves.
许多切罗基人，尤其是混血儿，信奉基督教。由于许多人像19世纪初文明的南方绅士一样生活，他们拥有繁荣的种植园，这意味着他们拥有黑人奴隶。
More than any other Native American tribe, the Cherokees adopted the religious, cultural, and political ideals of the United States, partly as a means to self-preservation.
切罗基人比任何其他美洲原住民部落都更接受美国的宗教、文化和政治理想，部分是作为自我保护的一种手段。
By becoming more like the Americans, they hoped to coexist with this new nation that was growing up around them. They weren't allowed to.
通过变得更像美国人，他们希望与这个在他们周围成长起来的新国家共存。他们没被允许。
Georgia settlers wanted their land and their gold, which was discovered near New Echota in 1829.
乔治亚州的定居者想要他们的土地和黄金，黄金是1829年在新埃科塔附近发现的。
They were really progressing so fast at this time period. The printing operation was going with their newspaper here. Things were moving so fast for them for a short while here that it looked very promising. But because of gold and the big demand for the land, their fate had already been really sealed for them in earlier years.
他们在这一时期进步非常快。印刷作业伴随着他们的报纸在这里进行。事情在短时间内发展得如此之快，以至于看起来非常有希望。但由于黄金和对土地的巨大需求，他们的命运早在前几年就已经注定了。
The tribe allowed Christian missionaries to live and work among them and to teach their children English. The most beloved of these was the Presbyterian Samuel Worcester, who built a two-story house at New Echota, which functioned as a post office, school, and rooming house. It's still there, and David Gomez walks us through.
该部落允许基督教传教士在他们中间生活和工作，并教他们的孩子英语。其中最受爱戴的是长老会教徒塞缪尔·伍斯特，他在新埃科塔建造了一栋两层楼的房子，充当邮局、学校和招待所。它至今仍在那里，大卫·戈麦斯领我们参观。
We've got some steep steps here. Y'all hold on as you go down. I don't want y'all to have a broken leg on the rest of your trip.
我们这里有一些陡峭的台阶。走下去的时候抓紧。我不希望你们在旅程的剩余时间里断腿。
The state of Georgia, which of all the Southern states treated the Cherokee with the most hostility, passed a number of alarming laws in the 1820s and '30s, undermining the sovereignty of the nation.
乔治亚州在所有南方州中对待切罗基人的敌意最强，在19世纪20年代和30年代通过了一系列令人震惊的法律，破坏了该民族的主权。
One of these laws required white settlers within the boundaries of the nation to obtain a permit from the state of Georgia. Samuel Worcester refused to apply for such a permit, arguing that he had the permission of the Cherokee to live on their lands and that should suffice.
其中一项法律要求居住在领土边界内的白人定居者必须获得乔治亚州的许可。塞缪尔·伍斯特拒绝申请此类许可，辩称他得到了切罗基人的许可住在他们的土地上，这就足够了。
Georgia arrested Worcester and imprisoned him for four years. Worcester appealed to the Supreme Court, and the case Worcester v. Georgia became a great victory for the tribe. The court, under Chief Justice John Marshall, ruled that the Cherokee Nation was just that-- a sovereign nation within the borders of the US, and therefore beholden only to the federal government, i.e. not under the jurisdiction of Georgia State laws.
乔治亚州逮捕了伍斯特并将他监禁了四年。伍斯特上诉至最高法院，“伍斯特诉乔治亚州案”成为该部落的一场伟大胜利。最高法院在首席大法官约翰·马歇尔的领导下裁定，切罗基民族就是——美国边境内的——一个主权民族，因此只对联邦政府负责，即不受乔治亚州法律管辖。
And the Cherokee Nation was elated. They thought, all right, the highest court in the land of the United States, this government that we're trying to copy, they've ruled in our favor. This is gonna be good.
切罗基人欣喜若狂。他们想，好吧，美国这片土地上的最高法院，这个我们试图效仿的政府，做出了有利于我们的裁决。这将是件好事。
And of course Andrew Jackson, who was pro-removal from the early years-- he had campaigned on that issue-- decided he wasn't gonna back the Supreme Court ruling.
当然，安德鲁·杰克逊，他从早年开始就支持驱逐——他曾以此议题进行竞选——决定不背书最高法院的裁决。
Think about that, what that means. Jackson is violating his own oath of office to uphold the Constitution.
想想看，那意味着什么。杰克逊违反了他自己维护宪法的就职誓言。
Anyway, the state of Georgia was thrilled when Jackson thumbed his nose at the court, and immediately dispatched teams to survey the Cherokee lands for a land lottery. Soon white settlers arrived here.
不管怎样，当杰克逊对法院嗤之以鼻时，乔治亚州欣喜若狂，并立即派遣小组去勘测切罗基土地进行土地彩票。很快，白人定居者就到了这里。
They show up two years later in 1834 with a land lottery deed, and with Georgia soldiers saying, I've got this land from the lottery. Get off of it.
他们两年后的1834年拿着土地彩票契约出现，带着乔治亚州士兵说：“我从彩票中得到了这块土地。滚开。”
One small constitutional violation that was part of the land grab, Georgia seized the Cherokee printing press, so they couldn't publicize their cause and win political support in states up North. The tribe was divided about what to do. Stay and fight, or demand cash for the land and head West? No one exploited this split more than Andrew Jackson. And no one annoyed Jackson like principal Chief John Ross.
乔治亚州夺走了切罗基人的印刷机，这是土地掠夺的一部分，导致他们无法公开自己的事业并在北部各州赢得政治支持。部落内部对该怎么做存在分歧。是留下来战斗，还是要求现金买断土地然后前往西部？没有人比安德鲁·杰克逊更利用这种分裂了。而且没有人像首席酋长约翰·罗斯那样让杰克逊恼火。
Ross was a Jeffersonian figure in almost every sense. A Founding Father of the Cherokee nation in its modern legal form, he preached to liberty while owning slaves. An educated gentleman planter, he was their chief from 1827 to 1866.
罗斯在几乎每一个意义上都是一个杰斐逊式的人物。作为切罗基民族现代法律形式的国父，他在拥有奴隶的同时宣扬自由。作为一位受过教育的绅士种植园主，他从1827年到1866年担任他们的酋长。
In his later years, he corresponded with Abraham Lincoln. In his early years, he was such a believer in the inherent justice of the American system that he lobbied relentlessly in Washington, DC, believing that once the Congress and the president understood that the Cherokee were a virtuous, sibling republic that they'd treat the tribe fairly, as equals.
晚年，他与亚伯拉罕·林肯通信。早年，他如此坚信美国制度的内在公正性，以至于他在华盛顿特区不懈地游说，认为一旦国会和总统明白切罗基人是一个有美德的姐妹共和国，他们就会公平地对待该部落，视他们为平等。
Once the state of Georgia began evicting the Cherokee, and John Ross among them, Ross wrote, "treated like dogs, we find ourselves fugitives, vagrants, and strangers in our own country."
一旦乔治亚州开始驱逐切罗基人，包括约翰·罗斯在内，罗斯写道：“像狗一样被对待，我们发现自己是自己国家里的逃犯、流浪者和陌生人。”
The vast majority of the tribe wanted to stay put and supported Ross, but around 100 men, including Phoenix editor Elias Boudinot and his brother Stand Watie, 100 in a tribe of 16,000, met at Boudinot's house in New Echota and signed a treaty with the US government.
绝大多数部落成员希望留在原处并支持罗斯，但大约100人，包括《凤凰报》编辑伊莱亚斯·布迪诺特和他的兄弟斯坦·瓦蒂——16000人部落中的100人——在新埃科塔的布迪诺特家中签署了一项与美国政府的条约。
They had no authority to do this. Called the Treaty of New Echota, it relinquished all Cherokee lands east of the Mississippi in exchange for land in the West. They figured, Georgia was already seizing Cherokee land. This might be the only way the Cherokee could get something for it.
他们无权这样做。这被称为《新埃科塔条约》，它放弃了密西西比河以东的所有切罗基土地，以换取西部的土地。他们想，乔治亚州已经在抢占切罗基土地了。这可能是切罗基人能为此换取补偿的唯一途径。
John Ross, whom the Georgia militia arrested so that he could not protest, was stunned. He accused the treaty party of treason. The rest of the 16,000 Cherokee signed a petition calling the treaty invalid and illegal. Congress ratified the treaty by only one vote, despite impassioned pleas on behalf of the Cherokee by senators Henry Clay and Davy Crockett. The tribe was given three years to remove themselves to the West.
约翰·罗斯（乔治亚民兵逮捕了他，使他无法抗议）惊呆了。他指责条约派叛国。其余的16000名切罗基人签署了一份请愿书，称该条约无效且非法。尽管参议员亨利·克雷和戴维·克罗基特代表切罗基人进行了充满激情的恳求，国会仍以一票之差批准了该条约。部落被给予三年时间迁往西部。
Now we're standing at the side of Elias Boudinot's house, where the infamous New Echota treaty was signed.
现在我们正站在伊莱亚斯·布迪诺特房子的一侧，著名的《新埃科塔条约》就是在这里签署的。
When the spring of '38 rolled around, about like right now, nobody was going anywhere. Georgia and the federal government thought they were gonna have some problems, and you had about 7,000 troops come in to forcibly remove the Cherokees from their farms, from their houses, and initially rounded up in what were known as forts or stockades, and then moved up into eastern Tennessee and northeastern Alabama to three immigration depots, where they were then transferred and then moved out on the Trail of Tears, as everybody knows it.
当38年的春天到来时，大概就像现在这样，没有人离开。乔治亚州和联邦政府认为他们会遇到一些问题，于是有大约7000名军队进入，将切罗基人从他们的农场、从他们的房子里强行驱离，最初聚集在所谓的堡垒或木栅栏里，然后转移到东田纳西州和东北阿拉巴马州的三个移民仓库，在那里他们被转移，然后踏上了大家所熟知的“眼泪之路”。
So technically this is the starting point for the Trail of Tears. For the individual Cherokees, it really started at their front door or wherever they were rounded up from, though.
所以从技术上讲，这是“眼泪之路”的起点。但对于个别切罗基人来说，它实际上是从他们的前门或他们被抓的地方开始的。
Amy and I want to step on it, this patch of grass where the treaty was signed, but we hesitate. It's not a grave, Gomez tells us, but that's what it feels like. We tiptoe onto it, this profane ground. And then we tiptoe away.
艾米和我想踏上那片草地，签署条约的那块地，但我们犹豫了。这不是坟墓，戈麦斯告诉我们，但感觉就是这样。我们蹑手蹑脚地走上去，在这片亵渎的土地上。然后我们又蹑手蹑脚地走开了。
Perhaps we should be embarrassed by certain discrepancies between our Trail of Tears and theirs. We're weak, we're decadent, we're Americans, which means road trip history buffs one minute, amnesiacs the next. We want to remember, except when we want to forget.
也许我们应该为我们的“眼泪之路”和他们的之间的某些差异感到尴尬。我们软弱、颓废、是美国人，这意味着我们上一分钟还是历史公路旅行爱好者，下一分钟就成了失忆症患者。我们想记住，除了我们想忘记的时候。
We register at the Chattanooga Choo Choo, the Chattanooga Choo Choo. It's a hotel now, a gloriously hokey, beautifully restored Holiday Inn, in which the lobby is the ornate dome of the old train station, and the rooms are turn-of-the-century rail cars parked out on the tracks.
我们在查塔努加“切切号”（Chattanooga Choo Choo）登记入住。它现在是一家酒店，一家华丽、古怪、装修精美的假日酒店，大厅是旧火车站华丽的圆顶，房间是停在轨道上的世纪之交铁路车厢。
We're in giggles the entire night for the simple reason that the phrase "choo choo" is completely addictive. We try to work it into every sentence. "What should we do for dinner? Stay here at the Choo Choo?" We end up going out for barbecue saying, "this is good, but I can't wait to get back to the Choo Choo."
我们整晚都在咯咯笑，原因很简单，“Choo Choo”（切切号）这个词完全让人上瘾。我们试着把它加到每个句子里。“晚餐我们该怎么办？留在这里的Choo Choo吗？”我们最后出去吃烧烤，说：“这很好，但我等不及要回到Choo Choo了。”
We watched The X-Files in our train car commenting, "is it just me, or is this show even better in the Choo Choo?" I sent email from my laptop just so that I can write, "Greetings from the Chattanooga Choo Choo," exclamation point. Number of times I just said "Choo Choo? Seven. Number of Choos? 14.
我们在我们的火车车厢里看《X档案》，评论说：“是我自己的感觉吗，还是这部剧在Choo Choo里看起来更好看？”我从笔记本电脑上发了邮件，只是为了能写：“来自查塔努加Choo Choo的问候”，感叹号。我刚才说“Choo Choo”的次数？7次。Choo的次数？14次。
Day two. Sadly, we check out of the Choo Choo and drive across town to Ross's Landing. It used to be where John Ross's ferry service carried people across the Tennessee River. But in 1838, it was one of the starting points for the water route of the Trail of Tears.
第二天。遗憾的是，我们退了Choo Choo的房，开车穿过城镇来到罗斯码头。这曾经是约翰·罗斯的渡轮服务运送人们过田纳西河的地方。但在1838年，它是“眼泪之路”水路起点之一。
I stand on the sand and read a weathered historical marker.
我站在沙滩上，阅读一个风化的历史标志。
"Established about 1816 by John Ross some 370 yards east of this point. It consisted of a ferry, warehouse, and landing. Cherokee parties left from the landing for the West in 1838, the same year the growing community took the name Chattanooga." And I'm sure there's no connection at all between those two points. That sounds so nice. They "left for the West." Bye-bye. Bon voyage.
“约1816年由约翰·罗斯在距此点东约370码处建立。它由一个渡轮、仓库和码头组成。1838年，切罗基团体从这里出发前往西部，同一年，成长中的社区取名查塔努加。”我敢肯定这两点之间根本没有联系。这听起来真好。他们“离开了西部”。再见。祝旅途愉快。
I haven't mentioned that Ross's Landing also functions as Chattanooga's tourist center. Up the hill from the river is the gigantic Tennessee Aquarium and an IMAX theater. The place is crawling with tourists, a crowd so generic and distinguishable from one another they swirled around us as a single t-shirt.
我还没提到罗斯码头也兼作查塔努加的旅游中心。山坡上是巨大的田纳西水族馆和IMAX影院。这里到处都是游客，人群是如此普通，彼此无法区分，他们像一件单件T恤一样在我们周围旋绕。
160 years ago, thousands of Cherokees came through this site. In the summer, they were forced onto boats and faced heat exhaustion and a drought that stranded them without water to drink. In the fall, they headed west by foot, eventually trudging barefoot through blizzards.
160年前，成千上万的切罗基人经过这个地点。夏天，他们被迫挤上船，面临中暑和一场让他们断水饮用的干旱。秋天，他们徒步向西，最终赤脚走过暴风雪。
Either way, they died of starvation, dysentery, diarrhea, and fatigue. A quarter of the tribe was gone. And here, in the shadow of the aquarium, the Trail of Tears is remembered by a series of quotations from disgruntled Native Americans carved into a concrete plaza.
无论如何，他们死于饥饿、痢疾、腹泻和疲劳。四分之一的部落消失了。在这里，在水族馆的阴影下，“眼泪之路”被刻在混凝土广场上的一系列不满的美洲原住民的引语所纪念。
One of the citations from a Cherokee named Dragging Canoe is from 1776.
其中一条引自1776年一位叫Dragging Canoe的切罗基人的引语。
"The white men have almost surrounded us, leaving us only a little spot of ground to stand upon. And it seems to be their intention to destroy us as a nation." Good call. We're moving diagonally across the sidewalk. And Andrew Jackson, in 1820, "It is high time to do away with the farce of treating with Indian tribes as separate nations." We'll step on that one.
“白人几乎包围了我们，只留给我们一小块土地立足。他们似乎打算把我们作为一个民族彻底消灭。”说得好。我们斜着穿过人行道。安德鲁·杰克逊在1820年说：“现在是时候结束那种把印第安部落当作独立民族来对待的闹剧了。”我们要踩在这一条上。
These cracks in the sidewalks, they are symbolic of broken promises.
人行道上的这些裂缝，象征着被打破的诺言。
Are you making that up?
你是编的吧？
No, it says right here, some of the pavers are cracked to symbolize the broken promises made to the Indians.
不，上面写着呢，有些铺路石裂开了，象征着对印第安人做出的违背诺言。
Hmm.
嗯。
Most Americans have had this experience. Most of us can name things our country has done that we find shameful, from the travesties everybody agrees were wrong, the Japanese internment camps or the late date of slavery's abolition, to murkier partisan arguments about legalized abortion or the Enola Gay.
大多数美国人都有过这种经历。我们大多数人都能说出我们国家做过的我们觉得可耻的事情，从每个人都同意是错误的暴行——日本集中营或奴隶制废除得太晚——到关于合法堕胎或艾诺拉·盖号的更模糊的党派争论。
World history has been a bloody business from the get-go, but the nausea we're suffering, standing on the broken promises at Ross's Landing, is peculiar to a democracy. Because in a democracy, we're all responsible for everything our government does.
世界历史从一开始就是血腥的，但我们现在感受到的那种恶心，站在罗斯码头破碎的诺言上，是民主国家特有的。因为在民主国家，我们所有人都要为政府所做的一切负责。
This is the letter from Ralph Waldo Emerson to President Martin van Buren in 1838. "A crime is projected that confounds our understandings by its magnitude, a crime that really deprives us as well as the Cherokee of a country.
这是拉尔夫·沃尔多·爱默生在1838年写给马丁·范布伦总统的信。“一项足以摧毁我们理解能力的罪行被计划着，一项真的让我们以及切罗基人失去国家的罪行。
For how could we call the conspiracy that should crush these poor Indians our government or the land that was coerced by their parting and dying imprecations our country anymore?
因为我们怎么能把摧毁这些可怜印第安人的阴谋称为我们的政府，或者把通过他们离别和临终咒骂而被迫夺取的土地再称为我们的国家呢？
You, sir, will bring down the renowned chair in which you sit into infamy if your seal is set to this instrument of perfidy, and the name of this nation, hitherto the sweet omen of religion and liberty, will stink to the world."
先生，如果你在这份背信弃义的文书上盖章，你那著名的椅子就会陷入耻辱，而这个国家的名字，迄今为止是宗教和自由的甜美预兆，将会在世界上发臭。”
And the path ends with a quotation from an unknown survivor of the Trail of Tears, who said, "long time we travel on way to new land. People feel bad when they leave old nation. Womens cry and make sad wails. Children and many men and all look sad like when friends die, but they say nothing and just put heads down and keep on go towards West. Many days pass, and people die very much. We bury close by trail."
道路以一位眼泪之路幸存者的引语结束，他说：“我们在去新土地的路上走了很长时间。人们离开旧民族时感觉很糟糕。女人们哭泣并发出悲伤的哀鸣。孩子们和许多男人以及所有人看起来都很悲伤，就像朋友去世时那样，但他们什么也没说，只是低下头，继续朝着西方走。许多天过去了，人们死了很多。我们把他们埋在路边。”
That last passage, especially the part about when friends die, bring us to tears. And we just stand there, looking off towards the Tennessee, brokenhearted.
最后那段话，特别是关于朋友去世时的部分，让我们流下了眼泪。我们就站在那里，看着田纳西河，心碎不已。
Meanwhile, there are little kids literally walking over these, words playing on them, making noise, having fun. We sort of hate them for a second. We ask a teacher who's with a group of fourth graders why she isn't talking to them about Cherokee history. And she says, normally she would, but it's the end of the school year, and this trip is their reward for being good. It sounds reasonable. I ask Amy if she thinks these kids should share our sadness.
与此同时，小孩子们真的在上面走来走去，大声说话，玩耍，玩得很开心。我们有一瞬间有点讨厌他们。我们问一位带着一群四年级学生的老师为什么不给他们讲切罗基历史。她说，通常她会讲，但现在是学年末，这次旅行是他们表现好的奖励。听起来很合理。我问艾米她是否认为这些孩子应该分担我们的悲伤。
Well, I think it's a sad story. I mean, it's sort of like the Holocaust. You don't have to be Jewish to think that that's definitely a sad part of history. And I think the Trail of Tears is America's version of genocide. And I mean, really, it started right over there.
嗯，我认为这是一个悲伤的故事。我是说，它有点像大屠杀。你不必是犹太人也会认为那是历史上绝对悲伤的一部分。我认为“眼泪之路”是美国版的大屠杀。我是说，真的，它就在那边开始了。
You look like you're about to hit something.
你看起来好像要打什么东西。
Still, I can't take my eyes off those children. I envied them. I want to join them. I'm an IMAX person. I had been to an IMAX theater just weeks before.
尽管如此，我的目光还是无法从那些孩子身上移开。我嫉妒他们。我想加入他们。我是个IMAX人。几周前我才去过IMAX影院。
I wanted to come on this trip to get a feel for this trail that made us, but standing here at Ross's Landing, it hits me how crazy that is. Suddenly, the only thing I get out of it is rage. Why should we keep going?
我来这次旅行是为了感受塑造我们的这条路，但站在罗斯码头，这让我意识到这有多疯狂。突然间，我从中得到的唯一东西就是愤怒。我们为什么要继续走下去？
I don't know. I don't know why. I don't know why we're here. I seriously don't. Like, I know it's an interesting story, and yes, we are always interested in our past, but I don't-- sometimes I wonder what good comes of that.
我不知道。我不知道为什么。我不知道我们为什么在这里。我真的不知道。就像，我知道这是一个有趣的故事，是的，我们总是对我们的过去感兴趣，但我不——有时我想知道这有什么好处。
I don't think it makes me a more contented person at all. In fact, I think I feel really haunted by all of this, and I feel very weighed down by the pain. Part of me thinks this whole thing is a mistake.
我不认为这让我变得更满足。事实上，我觉得自己被这一切所困扰，我觉得被痛苦压得喘不过气来。我的一部分认为整件事都是个错误。
And maybe I feel more knowing about it, but I mean, it's not like this is a story where the more you know, the better you'll feel. It's just the opposite. The more I learn, the worse I feel and the more hatred I feel towards this country that I still love, and therefore the more conflicted.
也许我对它了解得更多，但我是说，这并不是一个你知道得越多，感觉就越好的故事。恰恰相反。我学得越多，感觉就越糟糕，对我仍然热爱的这个国家感觉就越仇恨，因此也就越矛盾。
And it's just the most-- I just feel all this anger at everything, and we're standing next to this stupid aquarium building and talking to Coast Guard guys. And there are ducks around, and now there's a calliope? And I mean, I don't know. Now I just feel-- I feel worse. I feel worse.
这只是最——我对一切都感到愤怒，我们站在这个愚蠢的水族馆建筑旁边，和海岸警卫队的家伙们说话。周围有鸭子，现在还有风琴？我是说，我不知道。现在我只是感觉——我感觉更糟。我感觉更糟。
There are only so many hours a human being can stomach unfocused dread. I was tired, and confused, and depressed, and I needed the kind of respite that can only come from focused resentment. In the Trail of Tears saga, if there's one person you're allowed to hate, it's Andrew Jackson, the architect of the Indian removal policy.
一个人能忍受无目的恐惧的时间是有限的。我很累、困惑、沮丧，我需要那种只有通过专注的怨恨才能获得的喘息。在“眼泪之路”传奇中，如果你允许自己恨一个人，那就是安德鲁·杰克逊，印第安驱逐政策的建筑师。
And since the Trail of Tears passed through Nashville anyway, we stop at his plantation, the Hermitage.
而且既然“眼泪之路”无论如何都会经过纳什维尔，我们在他的种植园——冬宫（Hermitage）停了下来。
Sarah Vowell and her sister enter the enemy's bedroom. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
莎拉·沃威尔和她的妹妹进入了敌人的卧室。那会在一分钟内从芝加哥公共广播电台播出，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, a program about the past and what to make of the past. We continue with the story of Sarah Vowell and her sister, Amy, who are retracing the path of the Trail of Tears.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，关于过去以及如何看待过去的节目。我们继续莎拉·沃威尔和妹妹艾米的“眼泪之路”重走之旅。
They have just arrived, if you remember from before the break, at the home of the president responsible for the trail, somebody they hate and intend to keep hating, Andrew Jackson, who incidentally is one of President Trump's favorite presidents.
如果你们记得中断前的内容，她们刚刚到达了对这条路负责的总统的家中，一个她们痛恨并打算继续痛恨的人——安德鲁·杰克逊，顺便说一句，他是特朗普总统最喜欢的总统之一。
President Trump placed Jackson's portrait in the Oval Office. He spoke at Jackson's home to commemorate the 250th anniversary of Jackson's birth. In that speech, he called out Jackson as a people's president, like himself, out for the common man, somebody who defied the political class of his day.
特朗普总统把杰克逊的肖像放在了椭圆形办公室。他在杰克逊出生250周年纪念日时在杰克逊家中发表了演讲。在那次演讲中，他称杰克逊为像他自己一样的人民总统，为了普通人，一个敢于反抗当时政治阶级的人。
It was during the Revolution that Jackson first confronted and defied an arrogant elite. Does that sound familiar to you?
正是在革命期间，杰克逊第一次面对并反抗了傲慢的精英。这对你来说耳熟吗？
[CROWD CHEERING]
[人群欢呼]
I wonder why they keep talking about Trump and Jackson, Jackson and Trump. I know the feeling, Andrew.
我想知道为什么他们一直谈论特朗普和杰克逊，杰克逊和特朗普。我懂那种感觉，安德鲁。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So I pointed out earlier that today's program was first broadcast in 1998. In the years since Sarah and Amy visited Jackson's home, they've updated the exhibits. The museum there includes exhibits on slaves and on Native American removals that Jackson enacted. There's an audio tour that focuses entirely on the enslaved people who lived there. Again, from our original story, here's Sarah Vowell.
所以我之前指出，今天的节目最初是在1998年播出的。在莎拉和艾米访问杰克逊故居后的几年里，他们更新了展览。那里的博物馆增加了关于奴隶和杰克逊制定的美洲原住民驱逐政策的展览。有一个专门关注住在那里的被奴役人口的音频导览。再次引用我们最初的故事，这是莎拉·沃威尔。
The house and museum are closed to the public when we arrive because of astonishing tornado damage. Part of me wanted to destroy Andrew Jackson and everything he represented. Seeing all those hacked up trees made me feel like someone had beaten me to the punch.
我们到达时，房子和博物馆因龙卷风造成的惊人破坏而对公众关闭。我想摧毁安德鲁·杰克逊和一切他所代表的东西的愿望的一部分。看到所有那些被砍断的树木让我觉得有人抢在我前面做了这件事。
God, look at it. All the trees are down.
天哪，看看它。所有的树都倒了。
Yeah.
是的。
The wrath of God.
上帝的愤怒。
Inside there's no display mentioning Indian removal because, remarkably, there is no display about Jackson's presidency. Carolyn Brackett showed us around the house, a columned antebellum mansion that looks like a cross between Graceland and Tara. Unfortunately for my spite spree, I liked Carolyn Brackett. I felt bad for her. Like, she would point into the library and say Jackson subscribed to a lot of newspapers before his death. And I'd say, "was one of them The Cherokee Phoenix?" She wasn't sure. She wanted to show off the mansion's painstaking restoration.
里面没有任何提到印第安人驱逐的陈列，因为值得注意的是，没有关于杰克逊总统任期的陈列。卡罗琳·布拉凯特带我们参观了这所房子，一栋有圆柱的战前豪宅，看起来像是猫王故居雅园和《乱世佳人》中塔拉庄园的结合体。不幸的是，对于我的恶意发泄之旅，我喜欢卡罗琳·布拉凯特。我为她感到难过。比如，她会指着图书馆说杰克逊在去世前订阅了很多报纸。我会问：“其中一本是《切罗基凤凰报》吗？”她不确定。她想炫耀一下豪宅辛苦的修复工作。
All of the rooms that have original wallpaper, all of the paper was conserved and had to be cleaned with an eraser the size of a pencil eraser. So that was quite an undertaking. The portrait of Jackson was finished nine days before his death. I think he shows the wear and tear of his life in that portrait.
所有有原始壁纸的房间，所有的纸都被保护起来，必须用铅笔橡皮大小的橡皮擦清理。所以这是一项相当浩大的工程。杰克逊的画像在他去世前九天完成。我认为他在那幅肖像中展现了他一生的磨损和撕裂。
The one over the--
上面那幅——
He looks like he's sticking his head out of a car window.
他看起来像是把头伸出车窗外。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I guess he wasn't worrying about his hair much by then.
我想那时他不太担心自己的头发了。
Carolyn guides us past the flower garden planted by Jackson's wife, Rachel, and into the family graveyard. There are a few piddly headstones and one Greco-Roman monstrosity with an obelisk rising from the center.
卡罗琳指引我们经过杰克逊的妻子瑞秋种植的花园，走进家庭墓地。有一些破破烂烂的墓碑，中间有一座带有方尖碑的希腊罗马式的庞然大物。
Let me guess which one of these graves is Jackson's.
让我猜猜这些坟墓里哪一个是杰克逊的。
Here he is. He actually had this designed for Rachel and left room for himself. And these are other family members.
他就在这里。他实际上为瑞秋设计了这个，并为自己留了空间。这些是其他家庭成员。
I pull a book out of my backpack, a book with the subtitle Andrew Jackson and the Subjugation of the American Indian. Carolyn and Amy exchange a worried look.
我从背包里掏出一本书，书的副标题是《安德鲁·杰克逊与对美国印第安人的征服》。卡罗琳和艾米交换了一个担心的眼神。
Well, so I'm standing here on-- I'm standing here on Andrew Jackson's grave, and there is part of me, as a person of partly Cherokee descent, that wouldn't mind dancing on it, you know? I'd like-- there's a letter that Jackson wrote about the removal of the Southeastern tribes. And can you hold that? This is his opinion on the Southeastern tribes leaving their land.
好吧，我站在这里——我站在安德鲁·杰克逊的坟墓上，作为一个有部分切罗基血统的人，我的一部分并不介意在上面跳舞，你知道吗？我想——杰克逊写过一封关于驱逐东南部落的信。你能拿着那个吗？这是他对东南部落离开家园的看法。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
"Doubtless it will be painful to leave the graves of their fathers, but what do they more than our ancestors did nor than our children are doing? To better their condition in an unknown land, our forefathers left all that was dear in earthly objects. Our children by thousands yearly leave the land of their birth to seek new homes in distant regions."
“毫无疑问，离开他们祖先的坟墓是痛苦的，但他们做得比我们的祖先或我们的孩子正在做的更多吗？为了改善他们在一个未知土地上的状况，我们的祖先离开了所有亲爱的 earthly 对象。我们的孩子每年成千上万地离开他们出生的土地，在遥远的地区寻找新家。”
And then it ends, "Can it be cruel in the government when by events which it cannot control the Indian is made discontent in his ancient home to purchase his lands, give him a new and extensive territory, to pay the expense of his removal, and support him a year in his new abode? How many thousands of our own people would gladly embrace the opportunity of removing to the West on such conditions?"
然后它结尾写道：“当由于政府无法控制的事件，印第安人在其古老的家园中变得不满时，政府购买他们的土地，给他们一片新的广阔领土，支付他们搬迁的费用，并在他们的新住所支持他们一年，这可能是残忍的吗？我们自己的人民有多少成千上万会很高兴接受在这些条件下搬迁到西部的机会？”
I mean, there's something-- there's something nutty about Old Hickory in this passage, just the fact that he just thinks, well, to compare the removal of Indians from their land with the opportunity of his generation to just go out West. Do you think-- I mean, what do you make of that? Can you help me understand that mindset?
我是说，在这段话中，老山核桃（杰克逊的绰号）身上有些东西是疯狂的，仅仅因为他认为，好吧，将印第安人从他们的土地上驱逐与他那一代人仅仅去西部开辟机会进行比较。你认为——我是说，你怎么看待那个？你能帮我理解那种心态吗？
Probably not. I mean, the interesting thing about that era was that they really felt that they were preserving. This is how they justified it in their own minds, was that they were actually helping preserve it, that this was inevitable. It was the early thought of Manifest Destiny, that it was inevitable that this would happen.
大概不会。我的意思是，那个时代有趣的地方在于，他们真的觉得自己在进行保护。这就是他们在内心为自己辩解的方式，认为他们实际上是在帮助保护它，这一切都是不可避免的。这是“昭昭天命”的早期思想，认为这一切的发生是不可避免的。
Interestingly to me is, they never seemed to think that we were gonna settle the country all the way to the West, all the way to California. So if they just kept moving everybody further away, they would suddenly get to a point where there wasn't gonna be any settlement, which of course didn't happen.
有趣的是，他们似乎从未想过我们会一直定居到西部的尽头，一直到加利福尼亚。所以如果他们只是不断地把每个人赶得更远，他们就会突然到达一个没有定居点的地方，而那当然并没有发生。
We drive on into Kentucky, towards Hopkinsville. When the Trail of Tears passed through southern Kentucky in December of 1838, a traveler from Maine happened upon a group of Cherokees.
我们开车进入肯塔基州，前往霍普金斯维尔。“眼泪之路”在1838年12月经过肯塔基州南部时，一位来自缅因州的旅行者碰巧遇见了一群切罗基人。
He wrote, "We found them in the forest by a roadside, camped for the night under a severe fall of rain accompanied by heavy wind. Canvas for a shield against the inclemency of the weather and the cold, wet ground for a resting place.
他写道：“我们在路边的森林里发现了他们，他们在狂风暴雨中宿营。帆布作为遮蔽恶劣天气的盾牌，潮湿寒冷的地面作为休息的地方。
After the fatigue of the day, they spent the night. Several were then quite ill, and an aging man we were then informed was in the last struggles of death
在当天的疲劳之后，他们度过了那个夜晚。几个人当时病得很重，我们被告知一位上了年纪的人当时正处于垂死挣扎的最后阶段。
Even aged females, apparently ready to drop into the grave for traveling with heavy burdens attached to the back, on the sometimes frozen ground and the sometimes muddy streets with no covering for the feet, except for what nature had given them.
即使是年迈的女性，似乎也要掉进坟墓里，因为背负着沉重的负担旅行，在有时结冰的地面和有时泥泞的街道上，除了大自然给他们的之外，没有覆盖脚的东西。
We learned from the inhabitants on the road where the Indians passed that they buried 14 or 15 at every stopping place."
我们从路上的居民那里了解到，印第安人经过的地方，他们在每一个停靠点都埋葬了14或15人。”
John Ross's wife died in a place like this, in winter, of pneumonia. She had one blanket to protect herself from the weather, and she gave it to a sick child during a sleet storm.
约翰·罗斯的妻子就是在这样的地方死于肺炎的，在冬天。她只有一条毯子保护自己不受天气的影响，而在暴风雪中，她把它给了一个生病的孩子。
There's more. It gets worse. I always knew the Cherokee owned slaves, that they owned them in the East, and that they owned them in the West. Only in the course of this road trip did it occur to me that the slaves got to Indian Territory in the same manner as their masters, on the Trail of Tears.
还有更多。情况更糟。我一直知道切罗基人拥有奴隶，他们在东部拥有他们，在西部也拥有他们。只是在这次公路旅行中，我才想到奴隶们是以与其主人相同的方式到达印第安领地的——在眼泪之路上。
Can you imagine? As if being a slave wasn't bad enough? To be a slave to a tortured Indian made to walk halfway across the continent?
你能想象吗？好像成为奴隶还不够糟糕？成为一个被折磨的印第安人的奴隶，被迫步行半个大陆？
Day 3, Hopkinsville. We stopped here because it was on the map, but pulling into town, we saw signs for a Trail of Tears Memorial Park we didn't know about. It seemed like a good idea to go there.
第3天，霍普金斯维尔。我们在这里停下来是因为它在地图上，但在进入城镇时，我们看到了一个我们不知道的“眼泪之路纪念公园”的标志。去那里似乎是个好主意。
You work here?
你在这里工作吗？
Yes, I do.
是的，我是。
Mind if we bother you a second?
介意我们打扰你一下吗？
What you need?
你需要什么？
Can you tell me about what the origin of this place is, and why there's a park here, and how it came about?
你能告诉我这个地方的起源，为什么这里有个公园，它是怎么来的吗？
Hopkinsville was a ration stop along the way on the Trail of Tears. And the Cherokee camped here. They were here for a week or so. While they were here, two of their chiefs died, and they're buried up on the hillside. If you start here and walk up to the grave area, there are three bronze plaques on each one of the posts.
霍普金斯维尔是“眼泪之路”沿途的一个配给站。切罗基人在这里宿营。他们在这里待了一周左右。当他们在这里时，他们的两位酋长去世了，被埋在山坡上。如果你从这里开始走到墓地区域，每个柱子上都有三块青铜牌匾。
The last one, just before you enter the grave area, tells you about the two chiefs, Whitepath and Flysmith.
最后一块，就在你进入墓地区域之前，告诉你们关于两位酋长，怀特帕斯（Whitepath）和弗莱史密斯（Flysmith）的事。
The plaque nearest the grave says that Whitepath was one of the Cherokee who fought under Andrew Jackson in 1814 at the Battle of Horseshoe Bend. Jackson even gave Whitepath a watch for his bravery.
墓地旁边的牌匾说怀特帕斯是1814年在马蹄铁湾战役中跟随安德鲁·杰克逊作战的切罗基人之一。杰克逊甚至因为他的勇敢给了怀特帕斯一块手表。
In that battle, a Cherokee saved Jackson's life, which hints at the level of Jackson's betrayal of the tribe. Had a Cherokee not saved his life then, Whitepath and Flysmith might not be buried here beneath our feet.
在那场战斗中，一名切罗基人救了杰克逊的命，这暗示了杰克逊背叛该部落的程度。如果当时没有切罗基人救他的命，怀特帕斯和弗莱史密斯可能就不会埋葬在我们脚下的这里了。
The graves are up on a little hill. You can hear the highway down below, but still it's serene. Up until this moment, all the graves along the trail had been metaphorical. All through Tennessee, Amy and I kept saying, "we're driving over graves. We're driving over graves."
坟墓在一个小山丘上。你可以听到下面高速公路的声音，但还是很宁静。直到这一刻，沿途所有的坟墓都是隐喻性的。在整个田纳西州，艾米和我一直在说：“我们开车经过坟墓。我们开车经过坟墓。”
But even then, we just imagined them there, under the blacktop, off in the woods. But here the skeletons suddenly had faces, specific stories. The graves were real.
但即使那样，我们也只是想象它们在那里，在黑柏油路下，在树林里。但在这里，骨架突然有了脸，有了具体的故事。坟墓是真实的。
It took the Cherokee about six months to walk to Oklahoma. We're doing it in five days. Every 10 minutes, we cover the same amount of ground they covered in a day.
切罗基人花了大半年时间走到俄克拉荷马州。我们用5天时间完成了。每10分钟，我们走过的距离就相当于他们一天走过的距离。
We drive with the sun in our eyes, on back roads, through Kentucky. We duck into a remote section of downstate Illinois Chicagoans fear to tread. A plaque marks the spot where thousands of Cherokee camped, unable to cross the Mississippi because of floating ice. We cross it in under a minute.
我们在肯塔基州的乡间小路上，顶着阳光开车。我们钻进了芝加哥人不敢踏足的伊利诺伊州南部的一个偏远地区。一块牌匾标记了成千上万的切罗基人露营的地方，他们因为浮冰无法穿过密西西比河。我们在一分钟内就跨过了它。
I know we're going fast, but it doesn't feel fast. We plod through most of Missouri, stopping at yet another Trail of Tears State Park. There's actually a name for what we're doing. It's called heritage tourism, which sounds so grand, like it's gonna be one freaking epiphany after another. But after a while, we just read the signs without even getting out of the car. At the end of every day, we fall into our motel beds, wrecked.
我知道我们走得很快，但感觉并不快。我们吃力地走过密苏里州的大部分地区，在另一个“眼泪之路州立公园”停了下来。我们所做的事情实际上有一个名字。它被称为遗产旅游，听起来很宏大，好像它会是一个接一个的顿悟。但过了一会儿，我们甚至不用下车就能读完标志。每天结束时，我们都瘫倒在汽车旅馆的床上，精疲力竭。
Day 4, in the morning, we plow through Arkansas. We get to Fayetteville in the afternoon. We have lunch with two old roommates of mine, Brad and Leilani, who take us to a little Trail of Tears marker next to a high school parking lot.
第4天，早上我们穿过阿肯色州。下午到达费耶特维尔。我们和我以前的两个室友布拉德和蕾拉妮吃了午饭，他们带我们去了高中停车场旁的一个“眼泪之路”小标志。
That looks plaque-like, huh? "On this site in the summer of 1839, there camped 1,000 Cherokees, men, women, and children en and route to their home--"
那看起来像块牌匾，是吧？“在此地，1839年夏天，曾有1000名切罗基人、男人、女人和儿童宿营，他们前往家园的路上——”
The sign's facing a semi-circular arrangement of boulders. Anyone who's ever been to high school would recognize it immediately as the place students go to sneak cigarettes or get stoned. And once again, it's striking how the two American tendencies exist side by side, to remember our past and to completely ignore it and have fun.
标志正对着半圆形的巨石排列。任何上过高中的人都会立即认出它是学生们溜去抽烟或吸毒的地方。而且再一次，两种美国倾向并存是多么惊人，一边是记住我们的过去，另一边是完全无视它并享受乐趣。
Like how we treat all our national holidays. Don't we mourn the dead on Memorial Day with volleyball and sunscreen? Don't we, the people, commemorate the 4th of July by setting meat and bottle rockets on fire? Which makes a lot of sense, when you remember that a phrase as weird and whimsical as "the pursuit of happiness" sits right there in the second sentence of the founding document of the country.
就像我们对待所有国定假日的方式一样。我们不是在国殇日用排球和防晒霜来哀悼死者吗？我们这些人民，不是通过烧肉和瓶装火箭来纪念7月4日的吗？这很有意义，当你记得像“追求幸福”这样奇怪且异想天开的短语就坐在该国建国文件的第二句话里时。
[MUSIC - CHUCK BERRY, "BACK IN THE USA"]
[音乐 - 查克·贝里，“回到美国”]
The most happiness I find on the trip is when we're in the car and I can blare the Chuck Berry tape I brought. We drive the trail where thousands died, and I listen to the music and think, what are we supposed to do with the grisly past?
我在旅行中发现的最快乐的事情是我们在车里的时候，我可以大声播放我带来的查克·贝里磁带。我们开过成千上万死去的地方，我听着音乐思考，我们该拿惨痛的过去怎么办？
I feel a righteous anger and bitterness about every historical fact of what the American Nation did to the Cherokee. But at the same time, I'm an entirely American creature. I'm in love with this song and the country that gave birth to it.
我对美国国家对切罗基人所做的一切历史事实感到一种正义的愤怒和痛苦。但与此同时，我是一个完全美国化的生物。我热爱这首歌和孕育了它的国家。
Listening to "Back in the USA" while driving the Trail of Tears, I turn it over and over in my head. "It's a good country. It's a bad country. Good country. Bad country." And of course, it's both.
在驾驶眼泪之路时听着“回到美国”，我在脑海中一遍又一遍地翻来覆去。“这是一个好国家。这是一个坏国家。好国家。坏国家。”当然，两者都是。
"Welcome to Oklahoma, Native America." Huh. I don't remember the signs used to say that. Do you?
“欢迎来到俄克拉荷马，美洲原住民。”呵。我不记得以前的标志是这么说的了。你记得吗？
No. I think, didn't they used to say, "Oklahoma's OK"?
不。我想，它们以前是不是说“俄克拉荷马还可以（Oklahoma's OK）”？
Well--
嗯——
That's about right, too. It's OK.
那也差不多。它还可以。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Across the state line, we're in the Western Cherokee Nation. And the maddening thing, the heartbreaking, cruel, sad, cold fact is that northeastern Oklahoma looks exactly like northwestern Georgia. Same old trees, same old grassy farmland.
穿过州界，我们就在西部切罗基民族了。而令人抓狂、令人心碎、残酷、悲伤、冰冷的事实是，俄克拉荷马州东北部看起来和乔治亚州西北部一模一样。同样的旧树，同样的旧农田。
The Cherokee walked all this way, crossed rivers, suffered blizzards, buried their dead, and all for what? The same old land they left. We breeze through Tahlequah, the Cherokee capital. Even though the Trail of Tears officially stops there, our trail won't be over until we get to our hometown, Braggs. It's about 20 minutes away, and we plan on spending the evening with our aunts and uncles there.
切罗基人走了那么远，穿过河流，忍受暴风雪，埋葬死者，这一切都是为了什么？他们离开时的那片土地。我们轻松地穿过塔勒夸，那是切罗基首都。即使“眼泪之路”正式在那里停止，我们的路也不会结束，直到我们到达我们的家乡布拉格斯。大约20分钟路程，我们计划在那里和姑姑叔叔们度过傍晚。
[KNOCKING ON DOOR]
[敲门声]
Come inside, girls.
进来吧，女孩们。
Hi.
嗨。
It's so good to see you. How are you?
很高兴见到你们。你们好吗？
Hi, Aunt. Hi, uncles.
嗨，姑姑。嗨，叔叔。
I wanted to talk to my Uncle John A, my mother's brother. At 74, he's my oldest living relative. I asked him about his great grandfather Peter Parson, who came to Oklahoma on the Trail of Tears.
我想和我的叔叔约翰·A交谈，我母亲的兄弟。74岁，他是我最年长的在世亲戚。我问他关于曾祖父彼得·帕森的事情，他是通过“眼泪之路”来到俄克拉荷马州的。
He was 12 years old, and he grew up here from 12 years old. And he was a stone mason. And some of his work is still around Tahlequah. If you're going up to the village tomorrow, you'll see two big columns.
他当时12岁，从12岁起就在这里长大。他是个石匠。他的一些作品在塔勒夸周围依然存在。如果你明天去村子里，你会看到两根大圆柱。
He built those?
他建的那些？
He built-- he helped build those two columns. See, they built that right after they came up here.
他建了——他帮忙建了那两根柱子。看，那是他们搬到这里后立刻建的。
I didn't know that. The columns he's talking about, and there are actually three instead of two, are the great symbols of the Cherokee Nation in the West. For years, I've had an old photograph of them stuck on my refrigerator door. They're all that's left of the remains of the Cherokee Female Seminary, the very first public school for girls west of the Mississippi, which my great grandmother attended.
我不知道。他说的柱子，实际上有三根而不是两根，是西部切罗基民族的伟大象征。多年来，我冰箱门上一直贴着一张它们的旧照片。它们是切罗基女子神学院遗迹中仅存的东西，这是密西西比河以西第一所女子公立学校，我的曾祖母曾在那儿上学。
Everything about the journey until now has been a little world historical. Hearing that our ancestor helped build the columns is the first time I felt an actual familial connection to the story.
直到现在，旅程的一切都有点世界历史感。听到我们的祖先帮忙建造了这些柱子，是我第一次感到与这个故事有实际的家庭联系。
I ask John A about our family and the Cherokee presence in Oklahoma. I ask him a lot of off-topic questions about his service in World War II, mainly because I was dying to. I was never allowed to ask him about it when I was a kid.
我问约翰·A关于我们的家庭和切罗基人在俄克拉荷马州的存在。我问了他很多关于他在二战中服役的离题问题，主要是因为我非常想问。小时候我从不允许问他关于那件事的问题。
And then I asked him a mundane reporterly question about whether he thinks the state of Oklahoma has done a good job educating its students about American Indian history. He says yes, then jumps into a non sequitur about his own education that I haven't been able to stop thinking about since.
然后我问了他一个平凡的记者问题，问他是否认为俄克拉荷马州在教育学生了解美洲印第安历史方面做得很好。他说有，然后跳到了关于他自己教育的一个不合逻辑的问题，从那以后我一直无法停止思考。
I just wish that I could have maybe went to school a lot more. I didn't get no education. And that was one of my big faults.
我只是希望我可能能多去上学。我没受过教育。那是我的大缺点之一。
But when I was growing up, it took everybody to make a living. So I had to work. There's Hoy, he's got a master's degree in education, and I got the third grade. Did you know that?
但当我成长时，养活自己需要每个人付出努力。所以我不得不工作。那是霍伊，他有教育硕士学位，而我只上了三年级。你知道吗？
No, third grade?
不，三年级？
That's all I got, the third grade. Duke is about third or fourth grade. We didn't get no education. So what you learn, you can't afford to forget, you know.
这就是我全部的教育，三年级。杜克大约是三年级或四年级。我们没受过教育。所以你学到的东西，你负担不起忘记，你知道。
On this trip, I've been so wrapped up in all the stories of all the deaths on the Trail of Tears. Sitting there, listening to my uncle ask what if, I realized that there are lots of ways that lives are pummeled by history.
在这次旅行中，我一直沉浸在“眼泪之路”上所有死亡的故事中。坐在那里，听着我的叔叔问“如果……会怎样”，我意识到生命被历史重创的方式有很多种。
If the Trail of Tears is a glacier that inched its way West, my uncle is one of the boulders it deposited when it stopped. He had to work the farm. And then came the dust bowl, and then came the war. All these historical forces bore down on him, but he did not break.
如果“眼泪之路”是一条向西缓慢移动的冰川，我的叔叔就是它停止时沉积下的巨石之一。他不得不去农场工作。然后是沙尘暴，然后是战争。所有这些历史力量都压在他身上，但他没有崩溃。
Compared to him, compared to the people we descend from, I am free of history. I'm so free of history, I have to get in a car and drive seven states to find it.
与他相比，与我们所出身的人相比，我从历史中获得了自由。我从历史中如此自由，以至于我必须坐上车开过七个州去寻找它。
It's good to know where you're from, to know where your beginning is. And it really probably don't amount all that much, only just to oneself. It has nothing to do with you getting out here, doing what you're gonna do tomorrow, or a week or two from now. But at least if you wanna look back, you can look back maybe on this trip and say, well, I was down in the area there, where some of my ancestors originated from.
知道你来自哪里，知道你的起点在哪里是件好事。而且它可能真的没那么重要，只对一个人自己而言。它和你明天或者一两周后要去做的事情毫无关系。但至少如果你想回顾过去，你可以回顾这次旅行，也许说，好吧，我曾经在那片地区，我的一些祖先就是从那里起源的。
Day 5, Tsa-La-Gi.
第5天，Tsa-La-Gi。
Do you remember this, Amy?
你还记得这个吗，艾米？
What?
什么？
Do you remember this?
你记得这个吗？
Yeah, don't you?
嗯，你不记得了吗？
Yeah. I mean, we came here once a year. Those columns are a lot smaller than I remembered. I remember them just being these arrows into the sky, and they can't be more than, what, 20 feet tall?
是的。我是说，我们每年都来这里一次。那些柱子比我记忆中要小得多。我记得它们就像是插向天空的箭，它们肯定不超过20英尺高，对吧？
Oh, I think they're taller than that.
哦，我觉得它们比那个高。
Look, now we're at-- this is the amphitheater entrance. Oh, here's where you'd get your program. Walk up here. And there's the statue of Sequoyah.
看，现在我们在——这是露天剧场的入口。哦，这是你拿节目单的地方。往这走。那里是塞阔雅的雕像。
Over there is where the Phoenix would rise again.
那边是凤凰再次升起的地方。
Over there-- over there, isn't that-- down there on the right, that's where I remember Stand Watie would-- he was always throwing a fit.
那边——那边，不是那个吗——右边下面，那里我记得斯坦·瓦蒂会——他总是发脾气。
I thought he was over there.
我以为他在那边。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Unfortunately, due to loss of funding, the drama here at Tsa-La-Gi won't be performed this summer. Amy and I sit in the chairs where we first learned about the Trail of Tears and talk about our trip. Our experiences were different. She minored in Native American Studies in college. She not only owns a copy of Black Elk Speaks, she could quote from it. And for her, the trip was about empathy.
不幸的是，由于资金流失，Tsa-La-Gi这里的剧目今年夏天不会上演。艾米和我坐在我们第一次了解“眼泪之路”时的椅子上，谈论我们的旅行。我们的经历不同。她在大学辅修了美洲原住民研究。她不仅拥有一本《黑麋鹿如是说》，她还能引用其中的内容。对她来说，这次旅行是为了感同身受。
You know, I've been pretty close to tears sometimes, just thinking about the pain or whatever, like what the kids must've been thinking. Like, when we were driving, I just kept imagining the kids saying, where are we going? Where are we going? You know? Like, what is happening?
你知道，我有几次差点哭出来，只要想到那种痛苦之类的，比如孩子们当时在想什么。比如，当我们开车时，我一直想象孩子们说，我们要去哪？我们要去哪？你知道吗？我是说，发生了什么？
I guess I've been thinking about what it really must've been like.
我想我一直在思考那真的会是什么样。
I've been thinking about those kids, too. But the person I identify with most in this history is John Ross, the principal chief during the Trail of Tears, because he was caught between the two nations. He believed in the possibilities of the American Constitution enough to make sure the Cherokee had one, too. He believed in the liberties the Declaration of Independence promises and the civil rights the Constitution ensures.
我也一直在想那些孩子。但我在这段历史中最有共鸣的人是约翰·罗斯，在“眼泪之路”期间的首席酋长，因为他被夹在两个民族之间。他相信美国宪法的可能性，足以确保切罗基人也拥有一部。他相信《独立宣言》承诺的自由和宪法确保的公民权利。
And when the US betrayed not only the Cherokee but its own creed, I would guess that John Ross was not only angry, not only outraged, not only confused. I would guess that John Ross was a little brokenhearted. Because that's how I feel.
当美国不仅背叛了切罗基人，也背叛了自己的信仰时，我想约翰·罗斯不仅是愤怒，不仅是义愤填膺，不仅是困惑。我想约翰·罗斯有点心碎了。因为我就是这种感觉。
I've been experiencing the Trail of Tears not as a Cherokee, but as an American.
我一直在经历的“眼泪之路”不是作为一个切罗基人，而是作为一个美国人。
John Ridge, one of the signers of the Treaty of New Echota, once prophesied, "Cherokee blood, if not destroyed, will wind its courses in beings of fair complexions, who will read that their ancestors became civilized under the frowns of misfortunes and the causes of their enemies."
约翰·里奇，《新埃科塔条约》的签署人之一，曾经预言：“切罗基血统，如果不被摧毁，将在肤色白皙的人身上蜿蜒流淌，他们将读到他们的祖先是在不幸的皱眉和敌人的原因下变得文明的。”
He was talking about people like my sister and me. The story of the Trail of Tears, like the story of America, is as complicated as our Cherokee, Swedish, Scottish, English, French Seminole family tree. Just as our blood will never be pure, the Trail of Tears will never make sense.
他指的是像我妹妹和我这样的人。“眼泪之路”的故事，就像美国的故事一样，像我们的切罗基、瑞典、苏格兰、英国、法国塞米诺尔家谱一样复杂。就像我们的血统永远不会纯净一样，“眼泪之路”也永远不会说得通。
Sarah Vowell, she printed a version of this story about the Trail of Tears in her book, Take the Cannoli, Stories from the New World. But in the years since she told this story on the radio, she has written a number of surprisingly funny books, retelling some very grim American history. The Wordy Shipmates about the Puritans, a book on LaFayette, another book on Hawaii, one called Assassination Vacation. Just Google, and you'll see what I'm talking about.
莎拉·沃威尔，她在她的书《带上卡诺里：来自新世界的故事》中印刷了这个关于眼泪之路故事的版本。但在她在广播中讲述这个故事后的几年里，她写了许多令人惊讶的有趣书籍，重述了一些非常严峻的美国历史。《健谈的伙伴》关于清教徒，一本关于拉法叶的书，另一本关于夏威夷的书，一本叫《暗杀假期》。只需用谷歌搜索，你就会明白我在说什么。
[MUSIC - THE BAND, "TEARS OF RAGE"]
[音乐 - 乐队乐队，“愤怒的眼泪”]
Today's program was produced by Julie Snyder and myself, with Nancy Updike and Alix Spiegel. Senior editor for this show, Paul Tough. Contributing editors for today's show, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere, Sarah Vowell. Production help from Pat Hannah, Laura Doggit, and Sylvia Lemus.
今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德和我制作，南希·厄普戴克和阿利克斯·斯皮格尔协助。本节目的高级编辑是保罗·塔夫。今天节目的特约编辑是杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。制作协助来自帕特·汉娜、劳拉·多吉特和西尔维娅·莱穆斯。
Additional help on this rerun by Emanuele Berry, Noor Gill, Diane Wu, Nick Mott, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney. Special thanks today to Ben Loyd, Leilani Schweitzer, and Brad Summerhill, Pat and Jenny Vowell, and to Sarah's sister, Amy.
本次重播的额外帮助来自伊曼纽尔·贝里、努尔·吉尔、黛安·吴、尼克·莫特、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼。今天特别感谢本·洛伊德、蕾拉妮·施威策和布拉德·萨默希尔、帕特和珍妮·沃威尔，以及莎拉的妹妹艾米。
Lucian Truscott IV, who you heard at the beginning of the show talking about Monticello is a columnist at Salon who wrote about monuments to Jefferson for The New York Times. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to any of our over 700 programs for absolutely free.
你在节目开头听到谈论蒙蒂塞洛的卢西安·特拉斯科特四世是Salon的专栏作家，他曾为《纽约时报》撰写关于杰斐逊纪念碑的文章。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过700个节目中的任何一个。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who today is hearing our program from Chattanooga and asks--
像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他今天正在查塔努加收听我们的节目并询问——
Is it just me, or is this show even better in the Choo Choo?
是我自己的感觉吗，还是这部剧在Choo Choo里看起来更好看？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。